good morning Hank it's Monday on
Thursday I'm gonna be reading and
signing in Plainfield Indiana and then
on Friday I'm moving to the Netherlands
for two months I keep meaning to mention
to you that I'm moving to the
Netherlands for two months but there is
so much going on in a related story the
sound of my anxiety makes a song I think
when I get stressed out I like to play
Google autofill once again proves that
people are weird hey today I'm gonna
answer the questions people ask Google
the most beginning is my book it's my
boyfriend gay huh I wonder if it is my
husband's we have about our wives are
they cheating and what is their tax
status and people say men aren't
romantic Hank similarly homosexuality
never comes up if you google is my girl
all we want to know is that our
girlfriends are not cheating not crazy
and that our guns are not stolen off
topic Hank but the Venn diagram at
achill intersection between people who
google is my girlfriend cheating and
people who google is my gun stolen
worrysome right but about your possibly
gay boyfriend two things first human
sexuality is not an either/or
proposition and trying to deny its
complexity is going to make both you and
your partner miserable secondly let me
submit that this is not a question for
Google it is a question for your
boyfriend is my baby sick listen I know
why you're asking Google this question
you're asking because the alternative is
to put a thermometer in your baby's
rectum and your baby will look up of you
like I am NOT enjoying this and you'll
be like you know what this isn't my idea
of a fun Thursday night either and then
your baby will be like but I am
incapable of empathy but it is my sad
duty to inform you that while Google can
take a picture of your house it cannot
stick a thermometer inside your baby's
bottom that's your job sorry if your
baby's under six weeks old there's a
temperature over 101 call your doctor
immediately he's my boyfriend cheating
on me
yes is my baby teething yes is my
boyfriend losing interest well yeah
otherwise why would he be cheating on
you is my boyfriend cheating on me
quiz you want a quiz okay here is your
quiz did you just Google is my boyfriend
cheating on me if you answered yes he
may or may not be cheating on you but
there is definitely a problem it may be
that your boyfriend's cheating on you or
that he's untrustworthy or that you're
incapable of trust or that you don't
believe that you're good enough to
deserve his monogamous affection it may
be that you feel undervalued or that he
feels smothered but something has gone
wrong that Google cannot answer you have
to talk to your boyfriend
and sometimes those conversations will
result in breaking up and I know that
breaking up sucks but it is better than
having to
Google is my husband cheating is my baby
a boy or girl
probably a boy I mean it's a slight
probably but I'm going with it is my
boyfriend cheating come on seriously we
just went over this is my blood pressure
high probably you're very anxious about
your boyfriend and that cannot be good
for your health
ideally you want your blood pressure to
be in the green or the yellow not in the
orange of the red yet another example
Hank of why it's good to be green and
lastly is my baby sleeping too much okay
first off if your baby is eating enough
and gaining weight your baby is not
sleeping too much second off don't take
this personally but I hate you so
nerdfighters with boyfriends and
girlfriends talk to each other Hank
don't forget to be awesome I gotta go
upstairs and pack I will see you on
Wednesday